we're on problem 6363 Carlotta can drive
from her home to her office by one of
two possible routes if she must also
return by one of these routes what is
the distance of the shorter route so
essentially she has a long route to go
to her office that's her home
that's her office and then she has a
short route with fewer curves that's my
guess and she could go and come back by
one of the two with that kind of binary
statement number one statement number
one when she drives from her home to our
office by the shorter route and returns
by the longer route she drives a total
of 42 kilometres so when she goes this
way shorter out this way and then longer
out back it's 42 kilometres so shorter
plus longer is equal to 42 and that by
itself doesn't let me know what the
distance of the shorter route is
statement number two when she drives
both ways from her home to our office
and back by the longer route she drives
a total of 46 kilometres so she goes by
the longer route and then by the longer
route again so two times the longer
route is equal to 46 kilometres
well this by itself helps me figure out
what the longer route is the way I want
to know the distance of the shorter
route so this you know I could just
eyeball this it's the longer route is 23
kilometres but if you want to know the
distance of the shorter route you would
need this information as well and you
know whatever the shorter route plus 23
is equal to 42 so it's what the shorter
route is 19 kilometres so you need both
of the statements both statements are
sufficient but one by themselves are not
enough to figure out what the shorter
route is they ask for the longer route
just statement two could have been good
enough next question 64 is X greater
than Y X greater than Y my computer is
updating something
it's a little bit is X greater than Y
statement number one tells us that X is
equal to y plus two well let me think
about that no matter what Y is X is
going to be two more even if Y is a
negative a million X is still going to
be a bigger number it's gonna be two
more than negative a million if it's Y
is negative ten this will be negative
eight no matter what X will be greater
than Y so this is all a statement one is
sufficient statement number two
statement number two x over two is equal
to y -1 this doesn't look as clear there
so X is equal to two Y minus two so we
just have to come up with a condition
one y where Y is less than X and another
y where Y is greater than X and then we
would have proven our point so let's
think about it when y is zero when y is
here this is using statement number two
and y is zero what's X X is minus two so
that's a statement where Y is greater
than X and then when Y is I don't know
when y is equal to 10 what's X 20 X is
18 so this is a statement where Y is
less than X so statement number two
actually tells us nothing about whether
X is greater than Y or Y is greater than
X so statement number two is useless
statement number one alone is sufficient
next problem 65 if M is an integer is M
odd M statement number one statement
number one M divided by two not they
write a real big in bold
not even integer not even integer well
that doesn't tell me much
I mean that doesn't tell me that that
this is odd in fact it's not an even
integer but if this was an odd integer
then that means that M is an even
integer right anything that's divisible
by two and results in an integer right
that's essentially saying this is
divisible by two by definition is going
to be even so for example what if M
divided by 2 is equal to 3 right 3 is
not an even integer but still and would
equal 6 and then M would be even and I
mean they're not telling us much here M
divided by 2 could be equal to 2.5 in
which case M would be equal to 5 so then
it would be an odd integer so this by
itself doesn't give me much information
statement number two M minus 3 is an
even integer M minus 3 is even well this
is useful right if if enough if you
subtract an odd number from a number and
you get an even number this number is
going to be even and let's think about
that if I have an even number let's let
me just write a bunch of numbers let's
see X let me write x y and z and let's
say they're consecutive right actually
let me write it even better let's say
that X X is even let's say X is even
let's say X is odd then X plus 1 is
going to be what it's going to be even
right the next number will be even then
X plus 2 is going to be odd and then X
plus 3 is going to be even or and then
if you go the other way actually I
should have gone the other way first X
minus 1 would be even X minus 2 would be
odd and X minus 3 would be even right
when you subtract if you haven't if you
have an odd number and you subtract out
and if you subtract out an odd number
and you get an even number then this
number is going to be odd so this
statement 2 by itself is actually
sufficient and play around with some
numbers if that intuition doesn't make
sense
statement two by itself is sufficient to
solve this problem and you don't need
statement one at all next problem
66 what is the area of the triangular
region ABC above well they've drawn us a
little triangle so I will draw us a
triangle if our base and then it looks
it looks pretty symmetric I'll try to
draw it the way they drew it it's one
end the other end and then this is the
altitude good enough and then they label
it a b c d this is a right angle this is
X degrees all right what is the area of
the triangular region so area of a
triangle is base times height times 1/2
so if we can figure if we can do that
then we're all done 1 the product of BD
and AC is 20 so BD so BD times AC I'm
sorry BD times AC oh that's it so BD is
the height so so area let me just write
it area is equal to 1/2 times this
altitude BD times the base times AC
right statement number 1 they tell us
what BD times AC is they tell us that BD
times AC is equal to 20 so that
immediately follows if this thing is
equal to 20 then the area is equal to 10
you didn't have to figure that out so a
statement number 1 by itself is
sufficient statement number two X is
equal to 45 degrees this one's a little
bit more interesting X is equal to 45
degrees well I mean we could you know do
a little angle game we could say okay
this is a ninety degree angle and we
could say that
this is 90 this is 45 and this is going
to be 45 actually that's about where we
could stop and this tells us no
information about what any of the sides
are so you could imagine if this is 45
degrees but this could be a million mile
high triangle or it could be a nanometer
high trial we don't know it could be of
any size you could scale it up or down
this just tells us the degree in the
angle information so 2 by itself is
useless so for this one statement one
alone is sufficient to answer this
problem a next problem
67 what is the value of B plus C B plus
C all right number one they tell us that
a B plus C D plus AC plus B D is equal
to 6 and this file itself doesn't help
us much as it felt these A's and d's
here and we don't they could be anything
so we can't solve for B plus C but I'm
already suspecting that if we could
factor out the A's and the D somewhere
so we get so we can factor out the beef
plus C's then we might be able to to
figure out the numbers if we forgiven
more information about a and D statement
2 and they give us more information
about a and D a plus D is equal to 4 so
let me see if I can simplify this top
one let me see if I can factor out a
bunch of B plus C's so if we think about
it
let me think so if you take this term
and that term and you factor out the a
you get a let me do it in different
color so this term and that term is
equal to a times what B plus C B plus C
right you can multiply that out and you
get a B plus a C and then plus and let's
do the same thing with this term D
that's D times C plus B but we can
switch the order B plus C and if you
don't believe me that this equals this
multiply it out all I did is I group
a B in the AC terms and then factor out
the a and then I grouped the CD and the
BD terms and factored out the D and then
now we can we can factor out a B plus C
we can do the reverse just distributive
property again so now this equals a plus
D times B plus C right and if you don't
believe me just multiply B plus C times
a and then B plus C put times D and you
get that right that's just a
distributive property but now we're
ready to solve because they told us that
this thing is equal to 6 so this thing
is equal to 6 and they tell us that this
thing is equal to 4 this is equal to 4
so B plus C is going to be equal to 6
over 4 or 1 and a half and we're done
you need both statements together both
statements together are sufficient to
solve this problem